>> Mark: THAT IS HIM,
STEALING --
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
AND THE MAYOR BLAMES THE
PRESIDENT FOR ANY AND ALL
VIOLENCE IN THE STATE.
THE MAYOR HIMSELF IS ACTUALLY
DOING EVERYTHING HE CAN TO
ENCOURAGE ANARCHY.
A VIDEO RELEASED LAST WEEK SHOWS
A MAN SUCKER PUNCHING AN NYPD
OFFICER.
>> POTOMAC GET OFF, GET OFF, GET
OFF!
>> Mark: THE GUY IN THAT VIDEO
IS ALREADY BACK ON THE STREETS
HAVING BEEN RELEASED WITHOUT
BAIL.
OTHER CONVICTS ARE WALKING OUT
OF CUSTODY WITH FREE CHRISTMAS
GOODY BAGS FROM THE MAYOR'S
OFFICE.
UNDER A NEW PROGRAM AND BUILD A
BLOG OF CO'S NEW INMATE FROM THE
CARE OF THE CITY, GET GIFT CARDS
CARE OF THE CITY, GET GIFT CARDA
CARE OF THE CITY, GET GIFT CARDD
CARE OF THE CITY, GET GIFT CARDP
CARE OF THE CITY, GET GIFT CARDE
CARE OF THE CITY, GET GIFT CARDO
CARE OF THE CITY, GET GIFT CARDD
CARE OF THE CITY, GET GIFT CARDS
CARE OF THE CITY, GET GIFT CARDB
CARE OF THE CITY, GET GIFT CARDA
CARE OF THE CITY, GET GIFT CARDY
CARDS.
ACCORDING TO THE NEW YORK, EVEN
CONSIDERING GIVING CONVICTS FREE
CELL PHONES AS WELL.
AN ASSOCIATE EDITOR OF THE CITY
JOURNAL AND HE JOINS US, LISTEN,
FREE CELL PHONES FROM ANYBODY
THAT KNOWS ANYTHING ABOUT
CRIMINALS KNOWS THAT IS ACTUALLY
THEIR PREFERRED MEANS OF
COMMUNICATION.
WHY WOULD TAXPAYERS BE EXPECTED
TO FUND IT?
>> IT IS A GOOD QUESTION AND IT
MAKES SENSE FOR PEOPLE RELEASED
FROM PRISON AFTER TEN OR 12
YEARS TO GET A BUS TICKET, SOME
SPENDING MONEY.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
IN JAIL FOR RECORD VIOLENCE.
THEY DON'T HAVE THAT MUCH TO DO
TO GET BACK HOME OR GET
REINTEGRATED INTO THE COMMUNITY.
THE PROBLEM IS, I'M NOT SURE
THAT IS THEIR GOAL NECESSARILY.
YOU KNOW, THESE ARE GENERALLY
PEOPLE WHO HAVE COMMITTED CRIMES
AND ARE, YOU KNOW, BAD ACTORS.
BUT WHAT THIS SPEAKS TO, MARK MY
PROBLEM IN NEW YORK CITY WHERE
WE'VE IMPORTANT THE PRIORITY
THAT KEPT FOR 30 YEARS.
IT USED TO BE THAT WE WOULD
FOCUS ON THE LAW-ABIDING
CITIZENS TRYING TO KEEP THE
COMMUNITIES SAFE AND PROSECUTE
THE BAD GUYS.
BUT NOW, THE PRIORITIES ARE
REVERSED AND WE SEEM TO BE
WORRYING ABOUT THE BAD GUYS AND
HELPING THEM, MAKING SURE THEY
ARE NOT PUT IN JAIL AND LEAVE
LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS TO THEIR
TENDER MERCIES.
>> Mark: IT SEEMS TO ME
UNWINDING A QUARTER OF A CENTURY
OF EFFECTIVE POLICIES SINCE RUDY
GIULIANI INTRODUCED THE BROKEN
WINDOW TO THE NEW YORK POLICING.
AND GOING BACK REALLY TO ALMOST
CLICHED POLICIES OF THE 70s
AND UP '80s WERE THE DEMOCRATS
WERE WITH THE CRIMINAL
CLASS.
>> IT STARTED IN THE 60s,
REALLY, THE PEOPLE THAT WE NEED
TO WORRY ABOUT ARE THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE COMMITTING THE CRIMES
AND GOING TO JAIL.
AND THAT THE COMMUNITIES THAT
THEY PREY UPON WELL, THAT IS A
NATURAL STATE OF AFFAIRS.
>> Mark: THE CITY BECAME A
CITY BECAUSE WE FOCUSED ON
KEEPING COMMUNITIES SAFE,
KEEPING LAWBREAKERS FROM DOING G
KEEPING LAWBREAKERS FROM DOING A
KEEPING LAWBREAKERS FROM DOING F
KEEPING LAWBREAKERS FROM DOING T
KEEPING LAWBREAKERS FROM DOING ,
LITTERING, YOU KNOW, HANGING OU
OUT.
BEING DRUNK.
>> Mark: RIGHT.
>>
ARE BEHEADED FOR A BALTIMORE
SITUATION WHERE EFFECTIVELY THE
POLICE BECOME SO DEMORALIZED BYT
POLICE BECOME SO DEMORALIZED BYE
POLICE BECOME SO DEMORALIZED BYC
POLICE BECOME SO DEMORALIZED BYT
POLICE BECOME SO DEMORALIZED BYY
POLICE BECOME SO DEMORALIZED BYH
POLICE BECOME SO DEMORALIZED BYL
THAT THEY BASICALLY SAY SCREW
THIS.
I'M NOT GOING TO TAKE THIS FROM
YOU.
>> WE ARE NOT HEADING IN A GOOD
DIRECTION.
WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO BEFORE
WE UNWOUND WHERE WE ARE
BALTIMORE.
NEW YORK CITY IS CURRENTLY
RUNNING 300 HOMICIDES A YEAR.
BALTIMORE IS ABOUT A TENTH OF
THE POPULATION AND HAS MANY MORE
UP HOMICIDES.
BUT THINGS ARE LOOKING GOOD.
I WOULD SAY THE PENDULUM HAS YET